new at 11 tonight a pair of animal
rescue groups are scrambling now to save
the lives of two injured dogs one
discovered with all the telltale signs
of being used as a bait dog for fighting
workers in an industrial area discovered
a bloody beat up dog just crippled in an
abandoned car seat he was starving he
was tortured he was severely abused
volunteers with Vegas Pet Rescue project
rushed him to warm Hearts pet hospital
for life-saving treatment he was in a
really really bad shape his face was so
swollen he could not open his eyes his
ears are severely damaged it's suspected
he was a bait dog because his ears are
nearly chewed off dehydrated underweight
his body ravaged with infection x-rays
revealed a screw in his stomach and it
turns out this dog is deaf so he
couldn't even hear who was attacking
them or understand why his Rescuers
believe the young albino pit bull likely
suffered long-term abuse and then was
dumped he was found with a collar on
that is very reminiscent to those used
two chaining a bait dog gut he's resting
and responding to care he's been named
Hercules hoping his strength will help
him survive
as you can see there it is going to be a
long road to recovery for Hercules the
non-profit really appreciates prayers
donations you can give directly to the
Animal Hospital if you feel more
comfortable we have Vegas Pet Rescue
project details on our website at
8newsnow.com